hello everyone this is Amir from audio
science review I'm here with another
review that happens to have a story that
goes with it uh you'll get that message
as we go through this um speaker is an
older one from company called
av123 um the company went out of
business I don't remember when but this
speaker was uh uh designed and produced
around uh 15 16 years ago uh the model
number is X VOE is v in Italian means
voice uh it makes sense because it's a
center speaker that goes with a home
theater system kind of like the setup
that you see in our living
room and uh you might ask why would we
review a product that's that old and and
uh not from a major company the reason
for that is that the designer uh Danny
Richie uh from gr research uh actually
sells the exact same design as a kit so
he sells you the uh uh drivers and uh
you can build your own cabinet and if
you don't want to build your own cabinet
it'll sell you what is called a flat
pack which is basically the all the
pieces already the machine but you glue
it together and put it and assemble it
um it's an unusual by the way he calls
it the same thing it's called XV just
the same so this is a current product
you can buy from him uh gr Research In
addition to being a vintage uh uh
speaker by itself uh you can see it here
sitting on a stand that I had um but if
you look at the top it looks kind of
unusual in that uh these two drivers
have their own sealed enclosures uh that
they sit in so that part is normal but
then these three drivers here the two
midwoofers and the Twitter in the middle
actually opened this open space in here
um there's this uh foam this little EG
crate foam and that's sitting here
covering the left middle and the on the
right it's bulging because there's a
crossover under it I'll show that in a
minute and uh the back is uh open so
it's actually it's sold as an open
baffle uh hybrid speakers hybrid because
they're sealed and open baffled but it's
not a proper open baffled in that open
baffled means just a speaker hooked up
to a baffle with nothing on the other
side this on the other hand has this you
know sort of a box that's that it sits
in and it'll have Reflections off of
this these three sides and it'll get
resonances and so forth so it's uh it's
not what they advertise but anyway it is
sort of open in here uh there's this
mesh on it that is basically bent uh
around here in this corner and goes to
the back um you touch it it'll ring uh
unusual for somebody like uh Danny from
G research that always complains about
things that ring and enclosures dur not
solid yet here we have a piece of metal
that loves to uh you know ring and and
uh it's it's just screwed with wood
screws into this enclosure so it's not
even that secure
anyway um you can sort of see a picture
of it here but a better version of is to
look at the uh the kit that gr research
cells and you can see uh the
configuration again these two are the
sealed ones and this MTM as we call it
midwoofer tter midwoofer uh uh have this
Center section that is open to the back
like this uh it's a heavy speaker um
it's weighs 60 lb there only $500 when
it came out so in today's dolls I don't
know what that is $8 or $900 seemed like
a good value um Danny charges like5 or
$600 just for the parts that you have to
then build uh on this thing so it winds
up being rather expensive is also very
deep and large something that people
don't want as a center speaker these
days but uh you know we go along with
what what was already built so as usual
I put this on the clipple nearfield
scanner I was worried that these uh back
Reflections and the front Reflections
would combine and create a very complex
sound field so I up the measurement scan
to 2,000 points which means that it took
nearly 6 hours for the uh nearfield
scanners robotic system to scan and and
measure this produce something like a
1.4 gigabyte file
and uh once it goes through and crunches
the numbers and creates a sound field
for the whole speaker and then we can
extract useful information out of it
such as what is the on access response
looking directly there and what the off
access response looks like and what
popped out is uh something I've uh never
seen in a speaker in that the paas
response has this mountain in here like
Mount Fuji it's got a sharp Peak and
then it drops like a rock and then we
have this hole in here up to about uh 3
300 Hertz and then the speaker kind of
is okay but you can see how Jagged the
response is and it's just not flat it's
a lot of interferences and so forth uh
coming out uh could be the cabinet could
be you know different resonances it's
just not a pretty side directivity is
poor you can see in here in this uh uh
red and a blue line there should be
straight line if we can get them but
instead the sort of Speaker gets more
directional then less directional
they're more directional on this thing
so uh but the bigger problem is this I
mean you you can't have a speaker that
only plays one note at about 80 Hertz
and then it drops like a rock and then
you know you pick back up at 300 HZ
that's just going to destroy your uh
base performance um whenever I test
speakers uh you know we go through this
you know fancy measurement system with
clip hole but I also do a very simple
measurement which is I take a measure
the measurement mic and clipple and put
it point blank in front of each driver
and measure the response of them that
means that we basically are excluding
the other drivers and room the actual
levels are not quite accurate but there
as a diagnostic tool is pretty good I
call that near field measurement and you
can see the near field measurement so I
measured the uh basers once those
woofers and you can see the problem
clear as a day in here with this you
know strange Peak instead of being a
smooth you know roll off over here to go
with the midwoofer in here and then the
Twitter in here uh we can see the
Twitter response is not bad but the
midwoofer as it goes down it starts to
resonate and it picks back up and
creates all these other waves these
combine together to give us this
butchard you know chewed up response
elsewhere in the speaker so it's it's
really got multiple problems but again
the most glaring problem is is this so I
thought about you know what to do at
this point do I publish this review do I
go do my listening test and I L the 60
lb speakers two floors up where my uh
main two channel system is but before
listening to it I thought well I should
go and and check on Danny's website to
see if he's got measurements for his kit
and he doesn't have any so odd because
most of his designs has got measurements
in there and so I thought I'll write him
an email asking what is going on so um I
showed him this this measurement and
said hey hey what's you know do you have
the measurements he said no he doesn't
have the original measurement when he
designed it and he doesn't have a
measurement for his kid either but he
plans on doing that in the future which
I found kind of strange but nevertheless
I showed him this measurement and said
well you know what is going on is it
does this make sense to you he said no
this hole shouldn't be there and the
reason the hole's there is because you
have the woofer and the midwoofers uh
they're wired out of face I was like hm
here's the response of the woofer by
itself I showed them this picture next
and this this measurement doesn't care
what the midwoofer is doing because I'm
measuring the woofer very close to its
uh cone so the interference from the
other driver uh wouldn't be there but
again he wrote back so well you know
it's very obvious there the wiring
mistake in the thing and you can send it
to me I'll fix it I said now I'll go
ahead and take a look at it myself so I
opened the uh cross uh the center
portion of the uh speaker and found a
crossover there which was a relief I
didn't have to dig inside the boxes to
try to get to it I have no schematic for
it then it didn't give me a schematic so
the question is you know what you know
is the wiring correct or not I noticed
that they were pretty consistent using
red wire for positive and white for
negative so you can see I in negative
over here and and input here's the input
and and uh so that was a good sign and I
look over here and and that that also
matches it says High minus and high
positive now I went to the twwiter
Twitter I had my son with me who is very
has very good eyes and instantly notice
this on top that says low minus and low
positive the red wire goes to low
negative instead of going to low
positive it is in the same pattern as
the rest of these you can see white red
white red white red so to me I was like
well maybe they labeled the PC board
wrong you know and whoever was
assembling it knew that and and wired I
mean so looks more logical to have it
this way than to have the last pair be
reversed but uh you know let's be sure
so what I did was that I then uh took
apart this woer on the left because the
wires for the low went in here and I
checked that the the polarity of the
colors of the wires was correct uh in
that the red did go to positive in here
negative 1 to the negative and so all
the sort of evid evence pointed to this
you know this being miswired because the
technician just followed the pattern
rather than paying attention to what was
written so I unscrewed this thing and uh
flipped it over and um disal wires and
switched them
over um and then I went and measured it
again and these are the new measurements
as you can see the problem exist 100%
still I shouldn't say 100% 90% this dip
did get felt in you can see in here now
there this is higher dip than what we
had originally was a very sharp dip so
it appears that the uh the the fix was
proper as far as the two were out of
phase and uh so that was the right fix
to make it was just one of the problem
but a high order problem remains in that
we still have this nasty peak in here
it's way above all these things and then
we still have a major hole in the
response so uh my gu yes was correct
when I was expressing sort incredulity
to uh uh or skepticism to Danny saying
that hey I don't know that that's the
main problem and indeed it wasn't the
main problem so but I was still you know
in doubt of what's going on in here I
just don't think there's any speaker
designer that's this bad in designing a
warer for a speaker to have this kind of
response I mean I you know anybody even
doing their first DIY speaker design
wouldn't make a mistake to produce
something like this and so I went
Googling online for exv and see what
people say and I landed on an
interesting thread in another Forum
called audio Circle and audio circle is
Danny Richie the designer home Forum in
that that's how he interacts with with
his customers and and I think he a
sponsor there what have you and there
was somebody complaining that his ex
voce is boomy sounds boomy so my I'm
sorry not the X the ecstatic which is a
another speaker that Danny sells uh sort
of looks like this and uh we can get a
larger view yeah if you look in here it
actually looks very similar to our
speaker in that this MTM configuration
or with open baffle they here this time
they're proper in that there's no you
know a box behind them so they are you
know to open baffle and then there's two
drivers inside of one larger box rather
than two smaller boxes that we have so
from that point of view it seemed like a
similar design and certainly the drivers
look just like ours and uh what does he
find he's comparing this ecstatic which
is similar to our design in blue in here
and he has the X Omni which is another
speaker that uh Danny sells and that one
is ported and he says look in identical
location I was measure these two
speakers both from gr research both
Danny's designs one has a base response
that's in red and there's some room
modes and stuff so you get some tips and
what have you but look at what happens
when I put ecstatic in here there's this
massive peak in here well above the
average level of the uh uh speaker so
usually speakers when they have ups and
downs you know they don't all of a
sudden have a peak that's so much
stronger than the rest so that clearly
indicates the
resonance uh on this thing uh what's uh
nice is that we have uh oops you can't
see this so let me do
see if I can get it down here ah shoot
sorry apologize you can't see oh maybe
you can um but anyway these responses
are actually from uh Danny Richie so he
chimes in so we know he's seeing this
and uh his answer you know quickly said
that you know you need to work at your
room and there's some cancellations
there's no way the speaker can be that
way and by the way he told me the same
thing there's no way there's a hold
there and the speaker had a ER response
there uh but uh he didn't know who he
was dealing with cuz this member was
quite good he went through this
incredible analysis and you can see his
all the speakers microphones every
criticism that was made of what he's
doing to measure he dealt with and then
some and then he keeps chiming in and
then he told him to contact him Shar the
schematic with him and told them what to
do and throughout all this he kept
analyzing and analyzing constantly
proving that the peak should not be
there and specific to this ecstatic uh
speaker which is very similar he even
goes and does outdoor measurements I
mean this guy is
dedicated uh and he shows again that you
know there's a extra hump in here oops
you can't see there's an extra hump in
here that uh you know the other speaker
did not I mean look at all the speakers
he lined up to test and he shows how the
you know the one speaker has a wrong
base respon
so again this is very very similar to
our problem uh and here's Danny in here
goes on and on and on and uh this goes
to page two uh this is from 2019 by the
way so only three or four years ago
unlike our speaker do 15 years old this
is a rather fresh thread and uh you know
at the end it finishes with him actually
just sticking some Mass onto the speaker
trying to change their parameters when
he does that he gets a Mild improvement
and but still not a proper fix and the
threat sort of dies over here and uh no
response from anybody so I was
personally disappointed after finding
this that Danny didn't tell me that this
is this is a problem identical problem
was brought out by somebody else and it
had nothing to do with crossovers being
wired wrong or anything and uh he still
you know this guy still had it and the
reason we know that this cross overs
right because that was also told to him
and he dealt with all that and he proved
that his crossover is wired correctly
and so forth and by the way the
crossover looks almost identical or if
not identical to ours so very similar to
ours so you know so the mystery deepens
in here and gave me confidence that my
results were correct that indeed uh you
know this there's a serious design error
in in this speaker that is just going to
produce uh problem but before publishing
things the owner had bought this speaker
as a spare because he actually has a
full set already that he's using in B
spare just in case he needs the parts or
one of the speakers goes back so I said
hey why don't you measure your room uh
your's your version of sorry your
version of exv remember we were looking
at the exstatic which is another speaker
where you know the other person in audio
Circle was talking about but uh let's
make sure that it's not a sample issue
it isn't a one-off issue and so he makes
an in room measurement and in Room
measurements have a lot of ups and downs
but look at the base response exact same
Peak over here and look at the dip in
here right after it so clearly clearly
his sample which is another model that's
been manufactur byfactory has identical
problem in here so we have two models of
av123 XV Chase with a problem one
measured very accurately by me the other
one with in room measurement and it's
just a glare in glaring glaring problem
so that gave me confidence that we do
have a real issue in here and and you
know we've done everything we can to
diagnose the problem and uh I better go
finish the review so I went ahead and
and this is the you know capture the
rest of the measurements this tells you
the Reflections in a room and it just
shows you that just going to be a mess I
mean this is what hits the walls and
comes back at you and using computer
modeling we can uh predict what the
response would be if if you put the
speaker in your room which tells you
that you have one Basse note that'll
just produce and nothing else outside of
that and I know by the way there's some
variations elsewhere too depending on
where you draw the regression line um
one of the problems with this sort of
MTM configuration when you put uh a uh
two woofers together and a Twitter in
the middle is that when you're on AIS
everything is okay as you go off AIS a
little bit to right or left the sound
takes longer to come from one driver to
you than the other one and at certain
frequencies that extra delay causes the
the uh uh phase to invert and the sound
cancels and so what happens is that you
wind up with very narrow sweet spot so
as a result these kinds of MTM
configurations tend to be a major
compromise for home theater because home
theater you want to have a sofa multiple
people sitting you want to get a broad
Sweet Spot ironically as popular as
these things are they give you a narrow
sweet spot and we see that problem here
just as much as the physics predicts you
can see that the beam width Narrows
hugely so uh in this region where we
have the that MTM configuration
operating and you can get to plus or
minus 20° some speakers are as bad as
plus or minus 10 degree or 5 degree even
where even if you just move your head
few inches left and right the high is
will change or the mids will change here
20° if you sit far enough you're
probably okay but if you sit close to it
you're going to have a problem you can
see the same thing as sort of a heat map
you just how dramatic it is at these
frequencies basically
omnidirectional and then all of a sudden
you know the the beam width Narrows
tremendously and then expands the other
problem happens with these things that
all these Reflections that hit the walls
have different tonalities so the on axis
is this solid line here is fine it
doesn't care about that directionality
but the reflections that come out and
hit the sides and come at you the they
all have different tonality so that
changes makes the speaker Very Room
dependent uh depending on what room you
put it in it can have a completely
different tonality because what you hear
is a sum of direct sound and reflected
sound so these speakers tend to be
painted and Ne to optimize in a room as
opposed to one that has smooth dir
activity where these this is just all
same color like this and there's a
smooth drop off in here so many many
compromises many many issues in here uh
speaker looks Fancy with all these
drivers but no that it's it's not ideal
uh these speakers actually are fun if
you had them vertically if you took that
speaker put vertically which doesn't
make sense for a seter speaker but
vertically they actually have a smoother
response and they don't narrow but is
the horizontal which is the
problem uh a lot of bad news so far but
there's some good news when you use two
drivers instead of one one driver or one
that's a little bit larger is that the
you spread the power between the two of
them and that engine General lowers the
Distortion tremendously because you
don't have a single driver having to
have high Excursion you can have two
drivers have less Excursion and the base
Distortion is is quite low in here so
indicated like at 8060 vvl is way below
the uh threshold on this now it doesn't
produce much base so that's a problem
but but what it does produce seems to be
quite good um we get to the impedance
curve and you know I didn't notice at
the time but you can see how sharp this
point is around here at the same point
where there's a Mount Fuji response
usually there's a smoother curve but
this sharp Point indicates there's a
is usually I don't point out much in
this waterfall display I put it in there
because people ask about it um basically
it shows you frequency response over
time but it has a bunch of parameters
and depending on how you dial it you can
get any graph you want um here though
I'm highlighting all these resonances
anything that keeps going means that the
thing when you stop it'll keep ringing
turns out you don't need this graph
because you could look at wherever these
Peaks are and those sharp Peaks they all
caes reses so if he just had the
frequency response looked at all those
things you would know this intuitively
anyway but pictorially we see it in here
this is kind of important because Danny
from Jr research swears by this and he
mods many speakers from other
manufacturers and he makes measurements
of their waterfall and almost he never
I've never seen him show one as bad as
his own design here and he still
complains about him but look at this
like I mean it just you know any
waterfall this measurement of that
speaker would have shown all these
things that he hates and yet he doesn't
hate it and he sells this kit to people
and of course doesn't show you this
measurement for his own design so all
right so what does this mean um let's
listen to it uh I always listen to every
speaker and say hey are the measurements
correct maybe maybe made a mistake maybe
something wrong how hard about these
problems and uh I turned on the the
speaker and it's just I'm like is this
working you know just something sounds
quite wrong what I was hearing and where
I listened to it is is over here in our
living room I didn't have the energy to
Lug it upstairs again in my two channel
system but you know this is a typical
scenario anyway you got a flat panel you
got a center speaker and what I heard
was that the vocals were coming from
below the speaker and behind it not like
you know typically you put a speaker and
the sound IM from the speaker this thing
was like projecting the sound down and
below and sort of a
weird just sound that I'll talk about
this a little bit more later but I was
like this is just makes no sense I mean
this speaker is just it's flat out wrong
wrong wrong sound so I said well let's
fix the Bas first that we know is badly
broken and it's easy to fix with the EQ
so going down I I use a rune player so
lets me build as many of these
parametric EQ filters as I want I put in
a a filter in here that pulls down that
Peak at 80 85 htz or whatever it is 91
Herz and then I boosted that hole and
listen to it and that immediately
improved the Fidelity and the tonality
of even female vocals you think they
don't need much space but they do it
made the voice voices much Fuller much
more natural sounding once I put those
two in there speaker was then kind of
bright so I went in there put a couple
of uh broad um filters in here to deal
with you show there was some I showed
some the raggedness where he was sort
rising up and down and I pulled those
two down and that kind of worked uh but
the speaker was still sounding a little
bright to me and I guess that uh because
it it's we're sort of had a flat
response we really want to have a
response just like this so I putting a
filter in here where I boosted this
range of frequencies and then I
optimized these two by these three by by
ear and once I got to this point the
tonality of the base was good it never
got boomy I was hearing all the notes
before doing this by the way there was
no base till once in a while all of a
sudden you hear like something with play
a note with play at 90 Herz and then
other and then it would disappear it
would be base otherwise so it was very
very unnatural so I did all this stuff
and the speaker wasn't bright anymore
but I'm listening to it I'm like gosh
this thing doesn't sound clean doesn't
sound right I just I'm getting annoyed
that I constantly get the projection of
this sound coming from behind the
speaker uh I talked about it here is as
if you had your favorite favorite singer
Go sing in a public restroom a large
restroom and you keep the door open and
you go stand in the hallway you listen
to that that person it sort of sound
like sort of phy echoey but also distant
it just was all all wrong so I thought
maybe the uh Grill on top scrolling to
the top here the grill on top was uh
resonating and buzzing or something and
I want to put my ear close to it as I
got close to it all of sudden I noticed
this really crappy uh sorry crappy sound
coming out of the back of the speaker uh
clearly what and then I moved my head in
front of the Twitter and it was clear
and nice and good but get my ear back
here it's like oh my gosh this sound I
don't ever want to hear what comes out
of the back of this thing and it just
distorted poor sound these drivers
clearly are made to be producing sound
backwards in this little box in here
whatever is doing and so I was like what
to do what to do and uh I had this towel
handy and I grabbed this towel was a
fullsize bath towel and I put it on top
and dripped at 90° so it covered the
back and the top wow the transformation
was amazing amazing all of a sudden the
sound focused now and it was grounded in
the front of the speaker not that it was
coming out of the point swords this is a
large horizontal speaker so he had
pretty Grand presentation but now it
sounded right right and every time you
looked at the speaker you're like the
speaker is here but the sound is coming
down here it just made no sense and it
was this phazzy weird sound once I did
this this a speaker has good power
handling so you could Crank It Up and
our living room is massive it's got 30 4
foot 4 probably 30 foot ceilings and
very large space and this thing had no
trouble filling that room uh decent
subbase uh hand link uh it was not
playing him more than 10 or 20% but what
was there was only slightly distorted
was a bookshelf speaker would be
severely distorted and uh it was
actually nice it did make everything
sound rather Grand but but that's okay
you know a lot of music is probably fine
um but I tell you that towel was a great
fix uh on those things so if you have
this speaker you've got to you know
first apply Equalization and second you
got to just cover this stuff up however
you do it this is just a bad idea
there's a reason we don't see speakers
design this way and maybe the reason
this company want out of business and uh
on this things so the equalization
definitely definitely helps um so where
are we obviously we have a very broken
Design This is not a a proper speaker um
company has no measurements for it even
when there is measurements let's look at
the EA from gr research go down here and
you probably can't see it but the
measurements is shown for frequency
response starts at 200 htz our problem
is not at 200 htz our problem
is happens at below 200 Herz this is 200
Herz if you chopped off the measurement
here you would never see this dip and
this peak and and Danny forever insists
that nobody needs to see below 200 Hertz
because the room changes that response
anyway the room does change that
response but doesn't excuse you for
closing your eyes and designing speakers
without knowing what their base response
is when you do that you produce a
speaker like this because you've never
paid attention uh on this thing now why
does he limit it at 200 Herz is because
he measures speakers in a room and the
room has Reflections right um and you
don't want to show the reflections uh
when you say this is the response of the
speaker it has to be just a speaker not
room so what you can do is you can tell
the measurement system to stop accepting
data after so many milliseconds since
the reflections take time to arrive at
the measurement microphone doing that
basically gets rid of the Reflections in
a room it makes gives you an an aoic
chamber but there's a catch when you do
that you all of a sudden cannot get a
resolution at low frequencies the uh
smaller that time interval the less
frequency resolution you have so
basically anywhere from uh two to 300
Hertz are useless in his graphs anyway
all of this is way too smooth and then
he knows how bad it is below 200 Herz
and doesn't show you that
so uh you absolutely have to measure
down to 20 Herz as I do as I as every
magazine reviewer does and by the way if
you're a proper Audio company go outside
and measure it hire an eoic chamber hire
an agency to do the measurement for you
that's what a proper companies do when
you go to CF rev Val JB yeah noyman I
mean uh General like all these companies
either have anaco Chambers or they do
proper multiphase measurements where
they go outdoor measurements or they do
ground floor measur uh measurements and
and uh stitch them together there are
ways to do this uh magazines do it uh
but at least they give it a attempt it
may not be very accurate but at least
they try to just close your eyes and and
produce you know never and then on top
of that like I said if you go for uh
look at X vure
none of this exist anyway uh on this
thing and uh as I was after I post the
review it was interesting two more
people chimed in saying they have the
exact same peing problem and every one
of them same as the other person at
first confused this for their room modes
because room modes create these things
and they go then do all kinds of stuff
to the room and nothing fixes this peak
because it's not a function of the room
is a function of the speaker you have to
fix this in the speaker not in your room
but it it just looks like in room now
you could get lucky and you could have
room modes in here that kind of sort of
fill this up but it's just an example
that this is broken not only is it
broken in
xvo and av123 version of it or whoever
buys the kit but looks like all these
ecstatic uh uh speakers that Danny is
selling uh appears that all of them are
broken as well um so my hope is that
Danny goes and investigates this problem
and figures out a fix for his customers
for his future customers if the speaker
does produce this response I'm sure he
agrees this is not a speaker that's fit
for sale um and if it isn't he needs to
pull these kits off the market uh surely
he doesn't want to produce something
that just produces such bad sound for
people and uh you know he's got to be a
responsible seller now if I'm wrong and
he's got good measurements of this thing
let's see him but it's been a week since
I communicated with him and I haven't
seen anything back from him that he's
measured anything and he got better
response and we've got plenty of
evidence now that this is a broken
problem and that we know that Daddy
knows that this is a problem you know
given the issues that this guy brought
up in back in 2019 so it's a pretty
fresh
problem okay so I'll go ahead and stop
here uh it was a lot of work testing
this speaker um you took me you know
couple of weeks measuring on clip NFS
twice and uh uh you know at the end I
think it was worthwhile we discovered a
lot of problems in here and we showed
the power of measurements why you want
to measure down to low frequencies while
you need proper measurements yes clipple
nearfield scanner is expensive a
$100,000 system but you know if you're
going to be in the business of selling
products to people and you're making
hundreds of thousand of dollars or
millions of dollars Revenue you've got
to bite the bullet and if you can't do
it don't don't be in this business I
mean you either have the right tools or
you don't do it it's like you don't be
you know you could wish to become a
doctor but you can't say oh I don't want
to go to medical school I don't have the
money was like well then pick a
different profession same in here if you
can't measure down to 20 Herz and and
show proper response then then don't
don't be in this business and of course
Danny's uh good portion of his business
is buying commercial speakers from other
compan compies making measurements just
like I have and pointing out the
problems in it and go redesign the
speakers to fix them so I I hope there's
no complaint that hey you know why are
you you know Finding issues with him I
didn't seek out his speaker you know as
usual members reach out to me and offer
stuff and I test them and in this case
clearly uh his own house is not in order
on this thing okay hope you uh enjoyed
this review and uh got something out of
it uh I'll see you in a future review
bye-bye